Beth
what the hell are you doing
there's something that I gotta do
tomorrow dad and I want to be a married
woman when I do it
honey honey let's do this right right
let me plan I don't give a about
the wedding dad
I just hear about the marriage
sweetheart that's a priest
we aren't Catholic
that's all that matters
we're getting married
you okay with this Beth you are so
crazy
I thought you wanted to find a place
that was just ours
we will take that right I promise
sweetheart if it makes you happy I'm
happy
I'm happy there's two things I got to
grab the roofer just give me one second
all right
I'll be right back for groomers big guy
black hat
so you you stand here
and that you take her hand and you
walk her to what would be an altar and
you are I'm the best man you stand
beside him
I'm just a stall cleaner stall cleaner
can stay where he is and uh okay here we
go
at your wedding don't worry dad I won't
be wearing it long
Beth I'm not your buddy okay I'm here
your father so can you factor that into
our conversations going forward okay
ready
I love you
[Music]
I hope you let me do this again for you
and do it right
you can do it anywhere you want
all right
[Music]
who presents the bride me all right
for Honor father
[Music]
so normally I would say a few things
about the couple but
I don't have any idea who you people are
so I'll just move onward to the valves
I state your name
aye Rick wheeler do take State her name
to be my lawful wedded bride
take Beth Dunn to build my life away
Brad to have and to hold to honor and
cherish
from this day forward
For Better or Worse for richer or poorer
in sickness and in health
until death do us part
to honor
and to love
to cherish through everything
until I die
and that's no longer
and now miss Dutton repeat after me I
best done yes I do no
um not yet
you do I suppose
are there rings
oh hold on I have one
here it is
my mother's ring
we didn't have much about my poor but
it's yours
and so am I
[Music]
Now pronounce you husband and wife
thank you
[Music]
thank you uh
his father hope you're welcome
and don't worry
I won't press charges charges sorry
Daddy yeah I had to kidnap him
if I could get a ride back to my church
I appreciate it
how exactly did she get kidnapped you
it was just a little one
tiny come on
Jesus Christ
[Music]